[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact 10 vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
m
[Musique]
fini pour moi
et
[Musique]
au programme de double jeu retrouvé le
goût de la semaine brian ferries life
tools or le document laisse pas les
fortes sommes
rich and i'll be there gospel raf lui
ont dit oui à non plus les infos intox
de philippe guérin les bonnes bourde
laurent baffie philippe corti l'homme au
platine d'or et en invité vedette sacha
distel
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
m
oh
on
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
quand tu as rencontré celle qui allait
devenir sa femme francine qui bien sûr
avait peur de cette image sur fabriquer
de playboy était la tienne qu'est ce que
tu lui disais je voulais te dire que je
t'attends
et tant pis si le père montant s'ajoute
pas dit mais je lui ai dit je t'ai temps
jeu datant tout le temps ça on veut
décourager pourtant
et c'est là que tu lui a promis de te
ranger un petit peu des voitures c'est à
dire les copains et les boîtes de nuit
les castels et tout ça bien sûr je le
lui ai dit
je te promets le sel
vous baiser la babouche je te promets le
miel à la main qui de touches je te
promets le ciel
le sud est à cause des fleurs et des
ventes elle aux côtés lui soit 12 des
fleurs et des dentelles et elle était
comme en france in sur les pistes de ski
elle était si jolie
que je n'osais
ce ne peut
ou les
l ate est trop jolie
quand le vent l'emmener
elle était
si j'allais
je le
belle mémoire et après toutes ces années
tulle m comme en français moi je n'étais
rien voilà qu'aujourd'hui elle est le
gardien du sommeil de mes lui je vais
mourir dix mois sa charte qui a connu
quand même pas mal de filles à travers
toutes ces allées mais si tu devais
définir francine d'un seulement je le
sais sa façon d'être un mois parfois
vous déplaît aux tournées mois le
silence se fait
bel marc véron samoa
alors maintenant avec les hauts et les
bas de l'existence les enfants sont
grands
tous les deux ça va très bien 1 et
qu'est ce que tu lui dis la belle vie
[Musique]
bienvenue sur un double jeu alors dit
moi toutes les chansons qui viennent de
te servir de réponse sont contenues dans
ton nouveau cd et qui s'appelle comment
le titre général ces dédicaces
il ya toutes ces gens soir y en a
d'autres nouvelles des anciens est à
mélanger des chansons qui n'était pas à
toi avec des nouvelles chansons de toi
oui il ya principalement des chansons
qui ne sont pas de moi je ne sais pas ce
que j'avais envie de les chanter c'est
des belles chansons je pense que si
j'avais plus chanter ces chansons là
moment elles ont été écrites par
gainsbourg cabrel dabadie gignac hier
pierre michel jonasz après tout le monde
est cohérente
c'est des gens que j'aurais vraiment
aimé chanter alors je me suis passée
cette envie alors sasha on va être
obligé de faire une petite interview
check up
ouais tu es prêt ensuite toujours
presque comme chez le docteur tous les
scrutins
alors ton bon d'abord distel distel
c'est normalement c'est le non non mon
père et de mon grand père paternel après
ton prénom c'est parce achat parce que
ce n'est pas de sacha ils sont obligés
d'employer un mode moins il sait pas
mais enfin bon c'est alexandre pasquier
moral tout ne sais pas mais mon père
était d'origine russe et le l'employé de
mairie n'a pas voulu payer pas de salsa
cha je suis premier du nom du calendrier
télé surnom surnom autre que sacha de
loin
pas que je sache tout rancho date de
naissance 1933 la triste mézidon alors
ça veut dire que tu vas sûreté 60 ans
oui c'est mon inspiration la plus totale
c'est d'arriver être le plus beau
sexagénaire de la surface assez sur les
dix mois c'est quoi elle se crée alors
le secret un lifting non un plan non je
pense au contraire pour un garçon je
pense que c'est assez bien de 20 de
théâtre toi la vie mais les rides la vie
mais les cheveux blancs jusqu'au niveau
les garder c'est incroyable comme t'es
jamais rien fait non cigarettes n'ont
jamais fumé s'est connus je ne fume pas
je ne bois pas un nom de femme c'est
qu'un seul défaut cimentaire le nez il
est parfait voilà mieux ce sera un tout
neuf les dents c'est pas de moustache
mais les dans les danses et les hyènes
sais pas où tu peux y aller les yeux
sont beaux d'abord oui c'était bien
aussi
est ce que tu vois bien à très bien
c'est pas besoin de lunettes si de très
prés salés des rues non j'en ai eu
alors est ce que tu as fait ton test mon
test pour le sida ah oui je les fais je
les fais on n'y a pas longtemps du reste
c'est du cevu vu mes antécédents jeu
match mas m'astreins tous les ans ou
tous les deux ans faire un check-up tout
voir tout à fait là sans rien ces
sociétés mais aujourd'hui et alors
pendant que j étais un verre ferme qu'on
paie 200 pour voir si le métabolisme
ceci et truc cela lévita lisa du
maintien pendant combien
allons-y où est ben non on a eu peur moi
je tousse et je pense que c'est c'est on
est forcé d'avoir peur maintenant parce
que parce que malheureusement ça hein ça
galope vite et ça peut arriver partout
donc faut faire attention et on doit
voir donc les filles vous le savez il
n'y a pas de problème ex hr alors tant
que la russie a été l'urss toi pas trop
revendique était d origine russe mais
dans des cailloux gorbatchev non à la
tht a commencé à retrouver que tu par
les russes tu nous as fait j'ai passé
c'est la performance technique alors je
ne parle pas et alors tu nous as fait
une chanson sur gorbatchev qui était un
bide complet et je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi tu attends je vais d'abord te
rappeler les paroles
mihail votre regard laisse refléter
parfois ton de douceur qu'il semble
impossible de croire que vos paroles ne
sont que des leurres
je viens gorbatchev fouet ouais et alors
c'est d'angélique quand la délation rome
il ya d'autres choses qui sont moins
angélique dans la chanson est de dire
nous nous racontez pas d'histoire parce
que la chanson a pas marché parce que
quand on a écrit la chanson avec north
east aisés qui complique c'est mon ami
de toujours les événements étaient
tellement vite que finalement notre
chanson a été prise complètement de
court par ce qui s'est passé il a été
débordé avant même pratique alors faire
une sur lies in après
oui bon on peut en faire sur beaucoup de
choses mais alors il ya une date très
très dur dans ta vie c'est ans le 7
février 1942 quand ta mère a été arrêtée
par la par la milice ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé au petit jour que
tu étais quel âge tu avais le 42e les
neuf ans
je venais d'avoir neuf en fait parce que
je suis né le 29 janvier toi une semaine
près et ça se vend de tous âges des
choses comme ça ça s'est passé au petit
matin on a frappé à la porte c'est moi
je dormais mes parents depuis ces deux
cd des flics français du reste du
commissariat de la rue charron lagache
paris qui sont présentés en faisant
arrêter ma mère pour
faits de résistance et autre chose et
mon père a essayé de commencer de
l'ordre leur raconter des histoires
avant avant plutôt quand avant que nous
la porte il ya une porte de derrière toi
par la cuisine donc un peu compris ce
qui se passait quand des polices ou vas
y on essaie vraiment essayé de sortir à
toute allure par l'autre côté et puis il
y en avait un autre à deux côtés ces
gens là faisaient mais c'est pas des
allemands s'étaient serrés des français
est bon à l'embarquer puis voilà j'ai
essayé de chanter un peu c'est pour les
âmes a déjà trois petits singes savants
mouais côté comme il chante bien pouvoir
faire ça je peine à faire et donc ils
vous ont laissé avec ton père et ta mère
et l'embarqué et aujourd'hui quand la
sphère touvier jugé de la façon dont
elle a été jugée
je trouve ça pas très bien seulement
d'un homme d'un autre côté si tu veux
les
le temps passe tellement vite j'ai
tellement d'autres choses qui se font
si on doit rattraper tous les gens et
tuer tout le monde il resterait plus
beaucoup de monde sur cette terre encore
quand tu vois aujourd'hui dans la rue
des gens qui défilent avec le portrait
du maréchal pétain par exemple ça te
fait quoi
ça s'est passé il ya un mois alors très
honnêtement ça me fait pitié parce que
parce que je trouve qu'ils ont pas
compris grand chose qu'ils n'ont pas
réalisé en tout cas et ou alors
peut-être qu'ils ont vécu d'une autre
façon qui fait qu'ils ont peut-être des
droit de penser ce qu'ils pensent
montrez moi moi je prends c'est ce que
je pense je trouve ça débile et les
dérapages verbaux des chefs du front
national sur l'antisémitisme tu tu me
crame dérapages tu crains sa jeu
oui je je je crains tous les dérapages
du reste après l'arrestation de ta mère
ton père a décidé de t'éloigner yves
rémy ou au collège de l'immaculée
conception 12 bis rue crossardière la
mayenne tu sais pas si c'est très précis
mais tu vas y retrouver planqué là bas
alors oui oui complètement
et alors à la libération tu as été tué
était repris par tegra la libération il
ya un moment très jolie qui a été le 6
juin
c'est à dire le jour du débarquement des
alliés en normandie et il ya une panique
totale
alors nous a lâché me déboires elle et
partez partez faites ce que vous voulez
de la panique générale et c'est là où
mes grands-parents ventura donc ouais
mais vont retrouver quelques semaines
plus tard et m'ont fait chercher pour
que je les rejoigne
il invitait à pithiviers ouais il était
parti il avait émigré paix tu sais qu à
pithiviers 20 quand tu sais ça compte
dans l'express a fait un article ya un
an et à vingt camps de concentration
afin de regrouper les jambes alors
c'était très intense hier des temps près
de la souris si tu trouve effectivement
tes grands parents maternels et un jour
il ya quand même une scène qui a dû te
marrer part oui parce que c'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est que sept petits
déjeuners et mes grands parents avaient
loué nous mettait dans une petite maison
de campagne et 20 chemin qui menait
jusqu'à la route nationale 10 environ
150 mètres d'où je viens me suis une
dame arrivée est une dame avec des
cheveux complètement blanc que je ne
connaissais pas du tout et j'ai vu
arriver
et puis vraiment quand seulement ils ont
été à 15 mètres j'avoue je me suis rendu
compte de cette émeute a sauté par la
fenêtre a explosé la table du dic lui
est rendu compte ce jour-là que c'était
ça la chose la plus important cette voix
serrée ses parents sa ou ses enfants
concentre soit toi tu as été élevé dans
quelle religion alors alors
j'étais dons élevées dans pas de
religion au départ et dans la religion
catholique
à oman au moment de l'évacuation de
laval mayenne et l'or en 1920 1950 a
épousé et ta femme
oui je t'ai fait baptiser pour lui
fermer non j'étais non non non j'ai été
baptisé au collège de l'immaculée
conception de laval aujourd'hui est ce
que tu te sens comme beaucoup d'artistes
patrick bruel des gens comme ça est ce
que tu te sens aujourd'hui solidaires
d'israël de ce qui se passe en israël
pour la guerre du golfe pour la guerre
des six jours et quelques années je me
sens solidaire de de tous les gens qui
défendent une cause juste aider le
problème bon la cause israël c'est sûr
qu'elle est qu'elle est absolument juste
qu'il faut aimer est-ce que de l'autre
côté c'est à dire en palestine ou
ailleurs
il ya aussi des gens qui ont qui dès
qu'ils défendent leur cause et que leur
cody donc je serais plutôt pour défendre
l'accord qui doit se faire qui peut se
faire et qui devra se faire forcément
c'est dans l'ordre obligatoire de la vie
et du monde entre les gens qui de chaque
côté ont des causes justes défend bon tu
connais c'est serge gainsbourg je
connaissais bien serge gainsbourg tu as
regardé un truc sur gainsbourg entend
télévisée à regarde 8 juin 1967 la
guerre des six jours se termine l'egypte
est en pleine déroute et le sinaï aux
mains de chez dai hành qui commandent
saâles l'armée d'israël depuis le 18 mai
la communauté juive du monde entier
tremble pour l'existence de l'état
hébreu
artistes et intellectuels se mobilisent
parmi eux un certain lucien ginzburg
plus connu sous le nom de serge
gainsbourg qui décide de composer pour
l'armée d'israël ce qui sera la seule
marche militaire de sa carrière le sable
et le soldat
elle a été confirmée par serge
gainsbourg lui-même et aussi par une
lettre du père de gainsbourg joseph
ginsberg qui écrivait à sa fille et qui
a raconté cette anecdote comme en gaz
bourg a écrit cette mélodie sont un coin
de table est dans un état de rush
formidable je vois très bien à
gainsbourg en train de
rencontrez quelqu'un allait très bien
peut-être lui tiens ça serait une bonne
idée d'écrire une chanson gaz bouquet
sera bout de papier qui de meilleurs et
qui ces paroles la mélodie serait celle
d'élise à c'était une musique de film
sans laquelle gainsbourg travaillais à
l'époque est justement un film militaire
et donc il aurait plaqué dessus des
paroles pour encourager le moral des
troupes israéliennes
le 19 juin 1967 le journal l'express
publie les paroles de la marche
militaire de gainsbourg
si on les superpose à la musique
originale d'elisa voilà ce que ça donne
oui je défendrai quitte à mourir pour le
sait ça va pas du tout je ne crois pas
du tout que quinze borg les écrits et je
sais pas je connais son attachement pour
israël
peut-être pas comme la mienne il aurait
peut-être pas à les chanter pour les
soldats dans les hôpitaux mais de là à
écrire cela jane birkin ou confirmera
bien que gainsbourg a offert elisa
israël dernier détail révélateur
elisa est un anagramme d'israël à un air
prête un air bien connu d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et
elisa
et tout genre
recherche moyens
au fond ce bien
me doivent
chambre des cheveux
les auteurs
marche militaire pour israël s de l'info
os de l'intox
sacha distel à l'oreille ouais alors
mesdames messieurs pendant que vous
demandez si c'est de l'info ou si c'est
de l'intox
pendant que vous tapez sur votre minitel
pendant que mcenroe et agathe y
réfléchit qu'est-ce qu'on écoute parti
au lieu de me dire ce qu'on écoute mon
amour tu ferais mieux de lui demander de
se lever de se dépêcher d'aller chanter
mon amour sacha distel japonais
j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas mon amour
avant d'avoir eu rendez-vous
mon amour
oh
e
ou de plaies
sont là
chat
non
aux amis ou
le
et d'une
chanson
à votre avis
de l'amour
de vous à moi vous avez su
en un mot
vous déplaît
en dansant
chabanais
c'est mieux
non
chan
et là ça me fout
ah l'amour
chavez
avant vous
cet amour
e
on sent
le
aussant
la pluie de voleurs
c'est vous
[Musique]
non
le
rousseau
à tort
maintenant mcenroe service alors est-ce
de l'info est de l'intox info info
pourquoi bourg était capable de tout cas
ce beau était coupable de tout va mal tu
dis hein faut aussi je peux le dire je
peux le dire sacha tu m'as dit que
c'était de l'intox
tu va nous chanter quelque chose si t'as
perdu
alors on écoute l'expert jacky il est
désolé mon cher sasha en effet c'est de
l'info tout à fait de l'info sur un
commentaire écrit non simplement j'étais
en train d'essayer d'imaginer gainsbourg
en train d'entendre au rika zaraï
chanter cette marche militaire je pense
qu'il s'est remis à boire ceci dit ceci
d'une thunder a bien écrit il ya de
l'amour dans l'air kerry ya de l'amour
dans l'air ambiant éléments non mais
alors
un set partout bravo
maintenant
toi qui est un maniaque de la voiture tu
peux tu peux conduire je sais plus
combien de temps sans se fatiguer 16
heures sans dormir tu connais toutes les
routes par coeur
tu connais le nom des stations services
ouvertes la nuit
alors j'espère pour toi que tu n'es
jamais tomber sur un pompiste comme
celui que tu vas voir maintenant je te
le souhaite
ma fille mes batteries chaud
non
[Musique]
allez-y le ciel est sûre vous appuyez
dessus et a pas vous donner la pièce je
regarde genre
bonnet quoi la toile allez je vous ai
levé les essuie glaces comme ça vous
donnerez la pièce après quand vous aurez
fini de nettoyer
vous mettez du désert on est obligé de
vérifier les gens sont tellement cons
les frimas dissiper dans les diesels
inversement quand je parle à penser à ma
petite pièce oubliée parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui oublient
savoir jouer à ces petites bagnoles
attendait c'est quoi c'est bien un
pilier lg moins cher diesel
j'ai mis cinq longues balles de diesel
avancez vous allez tomber en panne il
faut faire la vidange la même chez
désolé non mais c'est un coup de vis en
france je les fais tout à l'heure ça
c'est pas un énorme
je plaisante pas je me du diesel
monsieur tenait à avancer on va on va
vite nettoyer interview water sénescence
oh merde merde merde merde merde j'ai
mis 5 handball il faut faire la vidange
et bien vous le faire même ça va coûter
1000 francs et là ils vont bientôt
changer ça va vous coûter 1000 francs et
avec nos pouvoirs s'est pas donné non
plus combien vous allez messieurs la wii
pouviez pas faire le plein ça convient
que 130 balles cette merde
bon allez payer et je puis vous voir ici
un attendait mais descend pas chez toi
servi à ta poubelle et ce qu'il veut
c'est mon métier ne faisait pas nous
servir monsieur aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est une rolls peut-être bien comment
elle est crade
est ce qu'on a dans l'est qu'elle soit
alors ok prenez le comme ça je vais vous
dire une bonne chose
les points total c'est pas à peine de
quoi c'est pas propre au total peut-être
vous êtes un jeune couple vous attendez
que ça pour faire un trousseau et
tiens le pin tu vois le pin's hop tu
vois plus voulez je vous en met un petit
coup sur le pare brise alors descendez
alors après d'abord je vous en mettre un
petit coup sur le pare-brise un
descendeur donc j'ai vu sur le pare
brise
allez-y malfaisants met un petit coup
sur le pare-brise déjà
toujours celle à la crédulité des gens à
quel point ils peuvent se laisser avoir
comme ça faut pas le dire parce que
c'est son gagne pain alors dix mois
après la guerre tu rentres en 5ème
agence en braille ou avoir cinq
émissions sera compliqué c'est long
c'est vrai mais on va y arriver
alors ton père bon il avait des magasins
d'appareils électroniques
weir d'abord 1 2 et à la madeleine à
saint-ouen c'est ça c'est un point
c'était c'était son marché aux puces
l'un des importants et amer
effectivement c'était la soeur aînée de
ray ventura ray qui était une star de
l'époque énorme rêvant tuera et ses
collégiens
alors j'aurai quand même comme tu
chantes bien j'ai quand même que tu nous
fasses quelques trucs de ray ventura
parce que moi j'adore ce style tout va
très bien madame la marquise par exemple
tout va très bien madame la marquise 2 à
très bientôt
pour tenter faux ils font que l'on vous
dise on déplore un tout petit la tan a
du mal à me coller parce que je connais
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
elle est de dire tout ça c'est écrit par
paul misraki tu as bien connu
fantastique musulin à trois ans je les
connaissais ses chansons moi je vois
cédait 2 le 10 mars et expliquant de
seconde le dimanche qui était le jour où
mes parents travaillaient donc puisque
samedi dimanche la lys et trois jours
d'ouverture sur puce et leur magasin
était situé sur le marché donc il
travaillait là et le dimanche comme on
ne savait pas quoi faire de moi puisque
j'allais à l'école alors j'allais chez
mes grands parents qui de relativement
voisins et et tonton va même si c'était
le mois d'août et là je sais pas il
restait très très tard on se marier et
le dimanche après midi quand il faisait
surface après avoir fait un gala selon
très tard le samedi il ya tout le monde
arrive et c'est à dire coquatrix misraki
en véronèse on a tous les grands de
cette époque-là guina banc des chansons
comme cela était là oui un peu moins
souvent que c'était après la guerre et
éco connaître plusieurs de leurs caisses
après lagacé d'henri salvador qui a pris
acte du guitariste chanteur et alors on
écrivaient les chansons et cette chanson
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
j'étais là pratiquement au moment où
elle a été écrite fait l'anneau est ce
qu'on l'attend pour
là qu'est ce qu'on attend pour faire la
fête
avec ben
le ciel est bleu il ya des chansons dans
le piano à queue et je me suis dit
qu'ils étaient engagés parce qu'ils
avaient pillé anneaux ou piano on peut
pas dire qu'il y avait une syllabe toi l
enfer de copiage en chaussée alors ta
première chanson la première chanson que
tu écris tu l'as fait entendre arrêt
ventura sans lui dire que c'était toi il
a fait semblant de croire dévalisé très
très très bien ouais enfin semble pas
comprendre ne pas voir c'était moi qui
pensait qu'elle avait vu tout de suite
il avait entendu et s'était pas très
bien et à bord et le disque suivant a
été a été le déclic
oui alors un jour tu tu ramènes des
états unis un airs du folklore américain
quitté les scoubidous donc c'est pas toi
qui a écrit la musique
non non non c'est un art folklorique
effectivement mais c'est pas vu les
états unis c'est s était à paris il y
avait une jeune chanteuse qui passent
dans les boîtes de jazz qui s'appelait
qui s'appelle toujours dents de scie le
huawei qui avait repris sa 2e une
américaine puis qui m'ont acceptée guéri
et il nous manquait une chanson un peu
marrant dans dans le tour de chant et en
entendant pratiquement la veille du
premier tour de chant ce truc chanté par
26 ça nous a donné l'idée c'était par
exactement la même chose mais d'avoir
une chanson de ces essais sont là qu'on
a on a écrit pratiquement dans la foulée
le sort des pommes des pas et des
scoubidous le mot scooby doo qui n'était
pas dans la chanson et c'est en faisant
chanter par les musiciens derrière pour
renforcer rythmiquement un petit peu la
chanson qu'on a eu l'idée en reste et a
eu l'idée en disant ça y est j'ai trouvé
la fille qu'elle vend pas des pommes des
poires et
autre chose elle vend des scoops des
pommes de cette ville où la chanson un
tel succès et scooby doo c'est un mot
est ce que les scoubidous contre et
c'est comme c'est venu de là les jeunes
qui ont fait un triomphe à cette chance
niable et par la même occasion un mois
ne sachant pas et tente énervé par ce
mode ne sais pas ce qu'il voulait dire
on y parfaire cette petite épissures
fils électriques même couleur et un jour
de l'été suivant gala au théâtre de
verdure de menton ils ont forcé un peu
les battre et ne tenait alors on a fait
ça le mot a été inventé en fait par
thésée quoi parler par les musiciens
oui oui ensuite a continué avec une ou
deux chansons qui était une adaptation
qui s'appelait auquel une nuit oui c'est
comment ça j'ai vu d'un trait de finale
aux trois whiskys et puis après quelques
porto avec ma fille d'aller à sa caméra
je voyais est tout petit
oh quelle personnalité moi j'écoutais
beaucoup de personnalité quand j'étais
petit a fait le mois saint mamert a
décidé de me marier
et non
oui à la balade hivernale prix tout doux
tout les gens célèbres de l'époque dont
le nom il fallait que ça se termine en
europe avait beaucoup et bardot et
bardot et jeanne moreau il avait dû les
grecs aux rimes et line renaud il y
avait
sais tu as fais de la télé en france
avec les sas à chaud et avec la avec la
belle ville et sasha show qui était que
les frontières entier mais déjà fait de
la télé en italie et label'vie qui
nantes je l'ait arrêté donné sa chance
un jeune s'appelle thierry ardisson il a
été remplacé tu as fais de la télé en
allemagne en italie en angleterre qu'est
ce qu'ils faisaient en angleterre je
fais plusieurs séries parce qu'on fait
pas ne fait pas de la télé comme ici sur
le plan des variétés c'est à dire que en
angleterre on te prend pour une série de
prêts ou de 26 émissions mais pas ad
vitam aeternam temps on veut bien de toi
ça devait de rendre fou tous ces voyages
sans arrêt ah oui j'ai souvent fait de
l'année où j'ai eu mon premier succès en
angleterre et toute la pluie tombe sur
moi j'ai fait en même temps l'olympia à
paris et j'ai rejoint pour toute la
campagne promotionnelle en angleterre je
passais même si c'est plus j'habite s
début j'étais je montrais un truc assez
fait scission des bons moments dans la
vie que tu vas voir un truc sur les
voyages la regarde mercredi 6 heures du
matin les premiers passagers du vol air
liberté pour berlin arrive à orly sud
ce voyage pas besoin de bagages car ce
soir on dormira dans son lit c'est la
nouvelle idée du club méditerranée avec
ces journées d'art que l'on pourrait
aussi appeler une vacance d'un jour on
visite en une journée et une seule une
grande ville européenne
aujourd'hui berlin
9 heures arrivés à berlin pas de
traditionnel bienvenue au club
mais les gens qui membres et les gentils
organisateurs prennent gentiment
l'autocar pour se rendre à la
pinacothèque du musée de daleh
évidemment on ne voit pas une ville en
un jour mais on a une idée ça donne
envie de revenir et ça donne de même une
coloration de la ville
13 heures fin de la visite et étape de
liaison jusqu'à une brasserie
berlinoises ont 14 ans est arrivée le
groupe au musée d'égyptologie sous le
regard serein de l'intéressé c'est de
l'image ou quelqu'un de bord de la
méditerranée où une jolie 40
oui une belle carotte vous savez à
samana qu'il ya des femmes qui
s'occupent bien mais ce n'est qu'en
saône-et-loire européen c'est presqu'à
n'est pas rien 15 heures ce n'était pas
prévu au programme
mais madame chaban delmas a décidé
d'aller rendre visite à cléopâtre dans
un autre musée vacances marathon tour
vacances marathon
16 heures le quart tombe en panne vite
le temps est toujours aussi précieux on
ira donc en taxi jusqu'à pergame ou
encore un autre musée la fatigue moi je
la trouve par kmm excessive on va avoir
une bonne nuit dans notre lit avec
l'oreiller auquel nous sommes habitués
il faudrait pouvoir le faire tous les
jours 17h30
on passe à l'est einstein checkpoint
charlie
un petit bout du mur et puis cap à
l'ouest pour un shopping exprès sur les
avenues berlinoise 18h30 rendez vous à
l'aéroport pour échanger ses souvenirs
de vacances et se relaxer les pieds des
formidables fatigant mais formidable
petit peu fatigué quand même vous le
dire je les ai ratées 23 heures arrivée
à paris on se pressent de rentrer chez
soi car demain c'est jeudi y est le
travail reprend on pourra alors
peut-être se reposer un peu l'onf les
séjours d'un jour à l'étranger s de
l'info est de l'intox sacha distel à
l'oreille ouais alors mesdames messieurs
pendant que vous réfléchissez pendant
que mcenroe et agassi font pareil
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute parti à bâtir et
tu vois mal coûte un truc qui s'appelle
les fortes offs et tu sais pourquoi ils
s'appellent les fantômes
parce qu'ils étaient quatre et top parce
qu'ils étaient au top et ça fait
j'attendrai mais c'est mieux c'est en
anglais
oh
non
m
ce week-end
yu
c
m
[Musique]
tu vois
ouais
le club med lance mes séjours d'un jour
à l'étranger s de l'info s de l'intox
agassi à toi de jouer
je cours d'hier un fou tu dis encore
info pourquoi parce que ça tu as réussi
la première fois en séries en peinture
vous pensez quoi vous comme sacha sacha
il a dit intox et toi intox intox aussi
normal
ouais non non mais bon on va voir on
écoute les experts jacky fait
un fou à
dans un commentaire jacky je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué comme ils sont
fatigués bon vous savez tout ce pour
quoi on va au club méditerranée
mais en une journée franchement ça va
intéresser qui les éjaculateurs précoces
mais ça va marcher thierry nom bien si
l'appel brême 2-1 pour lui bravo
[Applaudissements]
messieurs avant de parler d'amour avec
sacha distel
je voudrais que l'on écoute un grand
artiste qui vient pour la première fois
dans double jeu quelqu'un dont nous
apprécions les prises de position si
courageuse sur la couche d'ozone le
racisme le sida la guerre je veux parler
de patrick webb
je me suis un
jeter mon toutou
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je ne me
le soir
je me balade
avec mon essai
mais aucune
voix
aucune fille
et
i
car je ne suis pas patrick
non non non
je ne suis pas patrie
dans l'entendement
je fais souvent à la [ __ ]
[Musique]
bah
c'est sûr les gens mais pas verbe
et
l'assiette de risotto mais tous
ils me disent chao toutes les filles
[Applaudissements]
car je ne suis pas
rés
dans
jésus
attelé
entrant
je
qui va me tuer
m
quelle émotion pour la première fois
dans double jeu mesdames messieurs
c'était patrick bruel puisque je dis je
suis pas patrick bruel si enfin qu'après
huawei
kasha maintenant on est parti pour une
interview 12 ou alors je vais te dire
des noms de 2 pp plus tôt et tu vas me
dire s'il ya eu quelque chose ou rien et
c'est y pas de mentir un mmorpg chasse
gars parce que tu sais qui est un avocat
qui fréquentent cet homme bien et qui a
des relations fantastique avec certains
journaux offrent enfin je pense mes
filles m'ont fait juliette gréco par
exemple tu as j'adore ouais il s'est
passé quelque chose à tavaux et s'est
passé plein de saint john a pas de
problème d'avocats là ok ok ça a duré
longtemps à 2 2 en deux ans et demi
alors jeanne moreau est une aventure
entre vous sûr que ça veut dire les
aventures tu le dis dans ton livre sacha
sasha mais oui mais le manque pas mais
non il n'y a pas à ma cheminée serait
dommage qu'ils endurent une barre anti
art et essai yade et les gens ont une
vie et parce que d'autres tu dis des
choses légères et anodine dans quelques
fois c'est pas très bien pris par
certains médias ont souvent insistons
palatine alors brigitte bardot ça tu
viens c'est indéniable la rencontre est
très belle parce que en 1956 tu
superviser la bande son d'un film qui
s'appelle et dieu créa la femme pour les
productions de ray ventura qui
s'appelait versailles et tu vois arriver
un jour
bébé qui était présent tard elle était
avec jean louis trintignant dont est
très très amoureuse est en retard je
sais pas avant d'envisager c'est qu'elle
est en retard mais c'est pas quel était
le montech sont alors à ce moment là tu
leur gueule et ça commence vraiment
comme les films américains
j'avais loué un studio et coûté fort
cher pour le petit producteur que
c'était deux heures elle est arrivée une
heure en retard des corps même que c'est
que ça je n'avais pas lui parler comme
ça j'ai toujours eu une engueulade c'est
tout alors évidemment donc la france
entière attend vos attentes vos
fiançailles
oui moi cette époque là il fallait en
penser à se marier sa existerait en
attendant de se marier aux français pour
voir si allah on essayait de voir si tu
puisses l'a pas fait c'est dommage
pourquoi la rupture avec bardot parce
que parce que ces jeux tu sais que pour
rompre fait deux ouais donc il ya il ya
l'un et l'autre à leur but est parti
tourner un film donc j'étais pas là tout
le temps moi de mon côté j'avais pas
envie d'être le monsieur qui est
derrière toujours et que nous avons
visités monsieur bardot oui mais tu es
devenu l'ex fiancée de bardot s'était
pas mis à part un bon coup de je ne sais
pas moi je sais ce que je peux dire
c'est que maintenant ça c'était ans 58
ont en 92
ouais il y en a eu pas mal derrière qui
ont joué le rôle ray
présentement je sais par contre c'est le
ciel il a quitté en fait à winfrey
puisqu'elle s'est mariés juste derrière
ouais et a eu un enfant de l'ouest oui
même si toi tu voulais pu y penser à
bardos entend parler parce qu'un jour tu
es arrivée à oran de verdure et il y
avait quinze mille personnes quittent
ont sifflé parce qu'ils étaient en train
de charrier pas moi c'est l'histoire
telle que je ne connais que quinze mille
personnes si parlez-en coq et qu'aucune
annonce n'était pas quinze mille
personnes c'est une personne avant non
c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est sa
sentence à un petit peu comme daf qui
dirait tout d'un coup mais la toile et
non médical et il a compté 60 voix entre
deux chansons inédites c'est un cadre du
nord d'athènes une personne en plein air
presque met à crier que tu ne sais pas
pourquoi je l'espère sera là c'est plus
moi maintenant c'est l'autre sacré
virage dans sa carrière a mis les rieurs
de mon côté malade tu as dis quand même
c'est elle qui m'a fait le plus souffrir
dans ma vitrine
oui probable au ciel que tu m'épouser de
50 quand tu es tout jeune quand tu
amoureux faut dire quand même de la plus
belle fille du monde quand même faut
quand même dire elle est toujours une
des plus belles femmes du monde et que
tu te retrouve largué bombasse effectué
un double position de de l'amoureux
éconduit c'est déjà pas drôle n'est pas
un rôle facile il y avait à l'intérieur
de soi et en plus c'était la résine et
du monde entier qui peut être encore
plus difficile leur anneau citons aussi
difficile alors bon bah tu cèdes et
finalement tout a vraiment souffert
connaît le programme chinois avait déjà
perdu un ami
rassure toi tu l'a perdue c'est que
c'était pas un avenir est alors si ça
n'a pas marché c'est que ça ne peut pas
marcher un jour gros gros coup de foudre
donc tu rencontres ta femme s'est vue
est enfin on a enfin on arrive aux jo
voilà tu as changé de vie je veux dire
ça a été fini les boîtes les copains
elle t'a bien dressé un ouais c'est vrai
comment d'ailleurs à 2h des fiançailles
c'est vrai à 2h des fiançailles les
parties quinze jours pour réfléchir
non non c'est pas vrai c'est fascinant
il ya d'abord eu un déjeuner fantastique
avec mes grands copains les intimes
thouet dont claude brasseur dont un
daniel cauchy que tu connais ta petite
année mais oui tu vas pas te marier
tu n'as pas de mari moi je savais dès le
départ c'est là j'ai dit celle-là sapin
ça s'est vérifié et c'est j'en suis
heureux et alors il fallait pas trop
compte les admiratrices
c'est comme si patrick se marient demain
timor est arrivé et imagine catastrophe
nationale alors cette époque-là bon été
à tous dans ce genre de contexte et et
puis alors j'ai hésité puis francine a
fait ce qu'il fallait faire les bons que
je partais faire une tournée canada
etats unis et me dit bon écoute ci s'est
pas décidé quand tu reviens dans un mois
je suis plus la main elle n'était plus
là voilà je me suis retrouvé tout seul
elle en a fait voir en dix mois passés à
faire donc trente ans de mariage ou toi
tu à 60 ans non attends attends ça fait
29 ans de mariage et 59 ans ça va assez
vite comme ça c'est pas la peine
physiquement ça va entre vous à tout
seul ça va bien est en train de tout ça
va bien
j'ai un truc la team lagardère garde en
médecine on utilise parfois certains
produits pour des destinations
thérapeutiques différentes de leur but
initial exemple la prostaglandine un
médicament injecté avant chaque
opération aux nourrissons atteints de
malformations cardiaques
il permet une meilleure circulation du
son dans le canal artériel
mais on a découvert qu'il est aussi un
puissant remède contre la puissance
comme on utilise la prostaglandine pour
maintenir la perméabilité du canal
artériel
on peut utiliser ce produit dans le
diagnostic et le traitement de certaines
puissances en effet les mécanismes son
voisin puisque l'érection est due à un
phénomène de dilatation du corps
caverneux qui est permise par la
relaxation des fibres musculaires lisses
contenues dans ce corps caverneux
je suis atteint de l'impuissance
sexuelle au mondial m couché bon je me
fais une injection sur l'art sur la
verge et brioude et de l'érection c'est
ce ce fait immédiate
malgré l'intérêt et l'efficacité qu'on
lui trouve ce produit utilisé selon le
cas pour les enfants ou contre les
troubles sexuels n'est pas encore en
vente libre
on le trouve pour l'instant que dans les
hôpitaux de passe pour le moment je me
refuse à utiliser parce que je pense que
pour des profanes pour des patients qui
n'ont pas lu l'habitude des règles
d'asepsie il y a un vrai risque de
contamination à risque de l'infection
qui à mon avis n'est pas négligeable
dans la mesure où la manipulation du
produit sera facile dans des
dans des seringues toutes prêtes il est
évident que là il ya aucun problème
évidemment il utilisera albon céret ex
star du porno n'a jamais dit il connu de
panne mais pour lui la prostaglandine
utilisé chez les enfants est aussi un
vrai progrès pour les hommes trop s'en
sert pour le choc c'est pas plus mal non
plus ça permet à ses joies ses collages
etc man donkey peu connu quelques vaches
et ça va faire un chirurgien plasticien
fonds alloués à faire sur le continent à
ses produits permet de base et de se
sentir
je pense que c'est un bien ancien prenez
impuissance s de l'info s drogue
frêche est juste elle a l'oreille ouais
alors mesdames messieurs pendant que
vous demandez si c'est le remède
pendant que mcenroe et agassi
réfléchissent qu'est ce qu'on écoute
corti nous devons écouter les valeurs de
cette assemblée ce soir je te le mot
frère le diabétique parmi nous ce soir
et nous moi
deux plaies diffamer l'eau
[Musique]
globalement la crise n'avait pas porté
secours de bell
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'avait que deux
[Musique]
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un médical encore enfant qui soigne
aussi l'impuissance est mécano à toi de
jouer
intox intox pourquoi j'ai un enfant je
sais pas un enfant non mais je sais pas
et toi tant que ce fût intox 6 h m a dit
que c'était de l'intox ah oui parce que
c'est tout dans la tête docteur avant
donc les piqûres directement pas tu
crois pas tellement patronne on est bon
on écoute l'expert jacky avait raison il
faut puisque c'est de l'info c'est
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment comme vous avez pu
l'atteindre et pont-de-vaux est un
médicament qui fait boum des lots alors
moi je me pose une question yat il ya
t'il des exercices secondaire assaut par
exemple est-ce que c'est un médicament
qu'elle adresse ou d'affi le score 2-1
alors sasha avant de passer à des sujets
plus graves comme en avant de près afin
de passer des sujets plus graves
je voudrais que tu éclate de rire
dernière fois avec baffie le retour du
pont peace leur maintien
la première bouche de métro ici la plus
proche alors vous voulez aller où on
veut aller dans le vide 9e à l'hôpital
rothschild dalmau losique
quels services pertes allemandes et
professeur aux cliniques et alors là
c'est pareil c'est pour qui vous avez de
la famille la belgique et vous faire
qu'il a trahi la cua une bagarre atteint
maintenant il a tout plein neurologiques
au niveau des yeux d'une france qui sont
serrés et qu'est-ce qu'on lui a donnée
comme un vêtement hockey et qu'est-ce
qu'il est complètement
il a rien de bon je vais rater le
professeur là pour voir un peu le
traitement là parce que c'est normal
qu'ils n'aient pas eu de
j'ai avec ma mère on va lui rendre
visite pour je me suis garé porte
d'italie savoir la station pour pouvoir
venir
c'est vraiment c'est peut-être buttes
chaumont par là votre avis ouais mais ça
m'inquiète qu'il est parfaitement parce
que même en observation il pourrait lui
donner du clan védrines trois fois par
jour et punis j'aime bien le professeur
quand même je suis plus tranquille parce
que ça m'inquiète c'est quoi un visa
numéro de la chance c'est quoi il
s'appelle rappelé michel vachon apprécié
monsieur éviter d'être comme ça ça fait
d un peu le coude
soyez plus naturel mais voilà c'est
passé c'est la direction qui me demande
monsieur direction le patron monsieur
mouillart je me dis ouais il me dit le
type est un genre je vais dire à
direction et je suis comme ça non ça
fait quatre jours tapo pas marche pas
cette initiative lui dire si je fais ça
va passer
vous n'êtes pas [ __ ] le temps tu vas
tous n'ont pas d'hôpital a depuis tout à
l'heure on dit le mec là il est un genre
tout cas vers bienvenus c'est dingue non
on a dédié son coeur ouais je suis en
train de mettre les sens
cela dit c'est vrai que quand on voit
comme ça un rien ça fait un peu râler
bourrer la gueule à notre tâche avec toi
les bourrer la gueule une feuille à 3000
litres par mois rien n'a été fait le jeu
te fait le film à tort je te file le
pays maintenant non mais c'est une
blague
l'histoire
ce qui était drôle c'est que le
directeur de cette pompe était adorable
nous a reçus comme des rois on l'a fait
chier toute la chefferie de la femme au
pays ça casse y dix mois alors après
l'interview interlude check-up
l'interview ce vous maintenant je vais
faire une interview à peine d'art le
plus le moins tu es prêt oui le morceau
de toi que tu préfères le morceau de
musique la chanson je me méfie ils
roulent tous
à la bonne heure plus parce que nous on
était deux je pense que c'est la belle
vie la chanson de toi que tu détestes la
chanson moi monsieur cannibale ah oui
j'ai pas envie décrite mai mais c'est
pas vraiment été un des plus gros succès
de 10 et 200 m était je crois la chanson
qui a le plus rapporté d'argent à sa
salle une année et ça faisait comment la
messe est cannibale tintin tintin
je ne veux pas mourir oui mais à carhaix
pas qu'il était secrétaire g dommage que
ç'aurait été fait pour lui c'est le plus
grand moment de ta vie grand moment de
ma vie de ma naissance
ouais je n'ai pas pris conscience et le
pire moment de la ville
pire moment de ma vie
j'ai eu un
un moment donné
un problème de santé très important on
peut lire ou lille et celle issue fatale
était envisageable st croix parce que
pour réforme patrick sacha distel et
très en forme il ya eu deux concerts oui
qui n'avaient rien à voir l'un avec
l'autre mais tout le monde n'est pas
rien alors sa maîtrise médecins veulent
tout tout le monde fait dans sa vie
ouais 2 quand il déclare il déclare pas
prêt mais ils sont arrivés et visa à la
glande thyroïde way est un danseur de
une foire de pau quoi pas trop pas de
pause dans la peau d'un mélanome non
mais dis moi ce que tu as eu beaucoup de
courage parce que il ya toute une époque
où tu disais rien à personne est allé de
villejuif à l'olympia tapage et de la
chimio à villejuif le soir et il ya eu
un peu plus dit qu'il ya des centaines
de gens malheureusement qu'ils ont ça il
chante pas l'accabler soir alors oui il
faut autre chose est sûre le concert
gratuit le plus mauvais le plus mauvais
moment pour répondre à la question
c'était justement quand la première fois
on m'a dit bon voilà ce que vous avez et
on m'a convoqué d'urgence à l'hôpital
tout pour faire des analyses et je me
suis retrouvé sur le périph tu vois
allant à l'hôpital antoine béclère à
clamart et je voyais des mecs en volant
leurs gros camions qui raillent tu vois
pas ce qu'on n'aura pas à payer ceux ci
l'ont pas fait cela et ils sont si rares
et je les regarde
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont heureux si ça va
c'était même des moments toit se
souvient ce cliché la ta maman très
désagréable tu en est bien sorti chance
chance
cela dit moi et l'avion l'avion est
tombé oui c'était dans un avion oui
petit avion de location mais alors là tu
cesses jacquat pas y aller ouais c'est
le seul jour de ta vie ou tel était en
retard un gala y paraît oui j'ai même
pas fait le gala dieu c'est moi elle
seule que j'ai manqué il paraît que tu
as fan dans l'avion réciter son acte de
contrition
ouais c'est vrai au dernier moment elle
m'a dit viens viens viens des apps
essayer le pilote juste à côté elle
derrière la un avion de quatre places
garder moment après avoir volé vers 3h30
pour brûler les sens pas risquait
d'exploser si par hasard vous toucher
quelque chose en atterrissant une ligue
1 derrière j ai assez salée femme mourir
la main dans la main mais ils n'ont
abaissé la place du mort s'est pas passé
derrière et y avait le moteur à la place
il a tapé un moment tu as peur est un
pylône à haute tension face au milieu
des trucs sans dernier encore une fois
la compagnie baraka deal soit plus gros
coup de fric le fric
ouais je pense que c'est un
une publicité que j'ai fait pour une
télévision en angleterre qui est est tu
vends des quoi je vendais notre toilette
avait une eau de toilette je vendais pas
j'étais l'image de l'autre toilette
c'est une ligne d'eau toilette un petit
peu comme fabergé dont je leur avais
demandé de mettre leur présenta là on a
fait le monde entier avec ça je suis
écouté une chanson de taille critique
avec une autre toile est que tu as gagné
le plus d'argent si c'est pas malheureux
sur la plus grosse perte de frais car le
truc tu a coûté le plus chaud les
panneaux
merci
parce que là on a été bien secours venus
de toute façon je crois que c'est
probablement cette histoire de deux
comédies musicales jean heiremans cheval
et de chevaliers qui ne s'est pas faite
en 87 et dans laquelle j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup d'estimé mais je leur ferai
ouais c'est peut-être plus sexy en toi
un profit à bafia rien dit j'ai pensé
alors l'oeil gauche
non non c'est est-ce que c'est là qu'il
devient pas un truc regarde y'a plein de
superbe fille d'appareils non mais
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus sexy alors la
victime est française qui s'est tapé de
bien voir quelque chose à mon avis un
signe êtes forget mode yannick noah est
ce que tu as de moins sexy en toi je
sais pas qu'est-ce que j'ai des martyrs
ouais
philippe labro qui je tourne un film que
j'avais des mains d' assassin alors donc
il ya pratiquement passé en revue toute
ta vie
il ya un épisode dont tu nous a demandé
de pas parlé on n'en parle pas on en
parle après ma fille tu avais préparé un
costard de stars sur le thème que je
t'offrirai par contre on peut en
profiter pour parler de sécurité
routière
donc on va voir c'est vrai aussi c'est
important
regarde chaque année la route tue plus
de dix mille personnes en france
la saison la plus meurtrière et l'été
afin d'endiguer ce fléau l'opération
croix blanche pour la vie a été lancé
cette semaine
le principe en est simple partout où un
accident aura provoqué des blessés ou
des morts des croix seront peintes sur
la chaussée par les familles des
victimes des témoins ou encore par des
membres de l'association qui est à
l'initiative du projet
la ligue pour l'espoir sur la route mon
frère a péri avec toute sa famille lors
d'un accident de la route et je me suis
dit que c'était pas possible de rester
passif je crois que si tous les 20 ou 30
km il ya un certain nombre de croix
blanches parce qu'il ya eu des accidents
ça va quand même accepter les
conducteurs à la prudence et peut-être
leur rappeler qu'il faut appuyer donc
pas sur l'accélérateur mais un petit peu
sur le frein l'opération fait appel au
civisme de chacun
à l'instar de la journée drapeau blanc
organisé par antenne 2 il ya quelques
années le symbole du drapeau blanc
savait il avait bien savez bien banks
fonctionner et là je dois vous avouer
qu'avec votre opération croix blanche
bas c'est un peu le même style en ce
sens on veut marquer l'imagination des
automobilistes et moi je crois que tout
ce qu'on fait pour la sécurité
automobile
c'est bon c'est bon à planter je crois
qu'une croix blanche sur la route
montrant qu' un accident mortel
je crois que ça va ça va choquer
peut-être mais dans le bon sens mais
croix blanche pour la vie ne fait guère
recette auprès des décideurs
l'opération est boudé par la presse et
n'a pas reçu l'aval du ministère des
transports
nous sommes au courant de cette
initiative privée que nous trouvons
donneront tout à fait le droit mais nous
ne nous associons pas à cette initiative
privée car nous craignons qu'il y ait
des dérapages ce genre d'initiative le
principal souci de la sécurité routière
et devoirs des plaisantins tracé des
croix où bon leur semble l'opération
prendra fin le jour de l'automne d'ici
là les français auront peut-être appris
à respecter le symbole des croix
blanches
il y va de leur vie
si l'opération croix blanche sur les
routes de l'été s de l'info est de
l'intox h à l'oreille ouais alors
mesdames messieurs pendant que vous
réfléchissez pendant que mcenroe et
agassi font la même chose ici
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corps tu
irrésistible bryan ferry is like to love
pour toutes les filles qui nous
regardent
et
[Musique]
l'homme
après
elle
[Musique]
et
c'est ça
le
m
[Musique]
deuxième voie
c'est
m
[Musique]
oh
il
sur les routes de l'été s de l'info est
ce de la taxe agassi à toi de jouer
je veux dire un fou à faux pourquoi le
drapeau blanc croix blanche
ouais pourquoi pas d'accord et toi un
dock ce pourquoi je ne crois pas trop
mais toi tu m'as dit quoi le dialogue se
faire une croix rouge mais
ouais on s'y croit pas toi d'emplois
beaucoup et bien on va voir on écoute
l'expert jacky c'est bien tox absolument
moi je pense de toute façon qu'il ya des
moyens beaucoup moins morbide par
exemple toutes ces brésiliennes que la
chasse et du bois de boulogne sont les
placer sur les points stratégiques de la
route
ça ferait ralentir tous les
automobilistes vont y aurait un peu des
embouteillages mais il faut choisir dans
le dilemme embouteillages aux comores
c'est tout
et le score bien il y en a aucun des
deux qui a réussi à nike et l'autre
tie-break de croire tout tirs au but
alors à commencer par toi laurent boyer
animateur sur m6 vie avec alice dona etc
star du yéyé info ou intox intox
c'est de l'info assez les pénos était
resté ne devant pas mon avis à moi
kester ai dit ça s'appelle ans alors
c'est pour ça que vous avez vous vu pour
la ville pour une fois michel drucker a
publié une bande dessinée qui a pour
héroïne sa chienne zaza il faut bravo
bay martin
m
tu prends ton petit téléviseur tu
regardes les cadeaux philips qui
défilent et tu me dis celui que tu veux
des pannes
kenji kodama
la chaîne hifi colom une entièrement
nouvelle elle comprend un cd
programmables un ampli turbo basse
générateur un tuner une double platine
k7 autoreverse on l'applaudît vraquier
est ce que tu es prête confessé avoir
fait des vieux souvenirs
ouais je n'ai pas confessé depuis non tu
vas voir c'est pas mal tu me suis sa
cheville
[Musique]
sacha distel est il favorable au divorce
non s'il ya des enfants
s'il n'y a pas d'enfant était favorable
à la peine de mort dans certains cas
très précis oui particulièrement quand
il y as kidnapping d'enfants assassinat
l'enfant et quand cela est fait par des
gens qu'ils façon évidente recommencera
la légalisation des drogues douces ou
j'ai pas vraiment d'opinion oui pourquoi
pas dans les moments difficiles que tu
as eue dans ta vie est ce que dans ces
moments là est ce que tu t'es raccrocher
à l'idée de dieu est-ce que tu ne prit
pas
non je me suis raccroché à une idée de
quelque chose dans l'au delà
mais d'une façon tout à fait
inconsciente
j'ai plutôt une espèce de sens à ce mode
de la dérision et
ainsi de développement fantastique du
sens de l'humour qui me fait un peu
passées sur n'importe quel autre notion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu